today i'm going to show you a amazing
number and some of you may have come
across this before it's an absolute
classic but i i still think there's a
lot to be said about the number nine
six zero nine three
nine
three
four uh nine this is where it gets quite
interesting actually because it goes
nine eight
two three eight zero nine six you'll
notice actually this is one of the more
boring parts the number seven six zero
every time i mess this bit up hang on
that
that shouldn't be there i'll put
that in by accident sorry where was i 47
one
nine
and uh there it is that's the number i'm
going to talk about
today i still find this number
absolutely fascinating and the reason
this number is so great is because it
relates to a fantastic inequality a
formula if you will which i will put
underneath here so the formula we're
going to look at is a half
less than
the floor function of the mod function
of the floor function of the
y-coordinate on 17
floor function times 2 to the power of
negative 17 times the floor function of
x
subtract the mod
of the floor function of y again oh
that's floor sorry uh and that is mod 17
so i close that mod there and then this
whole thing once you got that you then
that open mod is two close that and then
close
the floor function okay so now we have
ridiculous number and we have ridiculous
equation to show you how the two are
linked i thought i would show you the
plot of this inequality because what
they're saying is if you have an x y
axis and you put for each point on that
plane you put in the x and y coordinates
into this formula it will tell you
whether or not you should color in that
point so in fact this tells you which
part of an xy plot should have a dot and
which shouldn't and i've got a printout
i have done of that formula and so if
you plot that formula you get this plot
here so this is the plot of that formula
and
in case you're wondering what is
particularly astounding about this the
formula when you plot it is itself it is
its own form it the formula is its own
plot the plot is the formula this is
called tupper's self-referential formula
and when you plot it you get itself and
that for me is one of them the freakiest
most bizarre parts of mathematics a
formula which is its own plot okay there
is however one slice cheat it does it
actually does that if you plot this
formula you get itself as its plot but
the cheat is this k down here because i
haven't actually specified where we are
on the vertical y-axis you can see on
the x-axis where 0-106 fairly normal
territory but here we're like k what on
earth is is that that k value is this
number here basically we are a long way
up the y axis right now if you go a huge
distance up the y axis of this plot and
you ignore everything else below it and
there's more after it ignore everything
above it at this one particular zone
between this number and this number plus
is where you get the equation that we
were using to plot them what's actually
amazing about top of the
self-referential formula is not that it
plots itself it's that it plots
everything as you go up the y axis it
plots every single 106 by 17 grid of
white and black pixels so anything that
fits in that grid is somewhere on this
plot so not only is tupper's formula in
the plot but also every other formula
you can fit into that size in fact i
found a different value of k which is
where it's the same formula but smiley
faces instead of the word mod and so
that's a slightly different value of k
gives you the smiley face version of
this formula also found the point where
pac-man is eating
the formula as chased by a ghost and so
that one is
i think that one's going to be higher up
as well
it's yes it's not far off though and so
every anything you can possibly fit into
one of these appears in there somewhere
and i can actually show you how you can
get from any picture you want to that
number the way it actually works is you
take the pixelated form of your equation
so let's get our original one let's do
where's the proper one and these
ridiculous ones okay here we go right so
there's there's the original one and
what you do is you start in the bottom
left hand corner and if you want that to
be a black pixel you put a one
and then you go to the one above it and
that's black as well so we put another
one and then the one above that is white
so we put a zero one above that is white
zero one zero one zero one zero
zero is that two or three looks like
three zero one zero and then you carry
on and you scroll up the first column
and then up the second column and up the
next one and you write it off as a
binary number and you end up at the very
end with a very long binary number you
then put that into base 10 you multiply
it by 17 and that gives you the k value
for where that plot appears on the graph
in fact this is a bitmap function and
the what jeff tupper was doing was
looking at using equations and being
able to plot them automatically using
software he's a computer scientist at
university of toronto and this is a kind
of a side effect it's an interesting
outcome of the legitimate proper
research he was doing in fact brady i
got you a present
i took the number file logo
pixelated it turned it into a binary
number
multiplied it by 17 put it into base 10
and there it is down there so that is
the k coordinate of the number file logo
on tupper's plot
okay so when i wrote my book things to
make and do in the fourth dimension
i happen to have it with me at all times
as you know ready i wanted to put in
type of self-referential formula and so
in the book uh here it is in the chapter
on functions i put in a picture of it
and i'm all like oh wow that's amazing
and then later on in the book when i get
to
digital images because it is just a
bitmap where is it
here we go i've got it again and i
explain the system and so there's the
actual plot there's if you turn it into
zeros and ones and there's when you
multiply it by 17 except
that's not actually the correct number
so the plot's correct the binary
number's correct but this is not because
i thought it would be hilarious to put
in a different number and so if anyone
ever does take that number and i've
never told anyone
penguin don't know this
fsg who published it in the us don't
know this i've not revealed it to anyone
it's the first public release this
information if you reverse that number
you get a different plot i have to face
the plot for that number this is the
world's
slowest longest running troll you will
ever come across so hopefully you know
years from now someone may finally get
around to doing it and they will not be
faced with that plot